[Music]
welcome ladies and gentlemen to the
water wars now as you know life has
become way too easy for everyone and
we've started to buy more and more
stupid things we don't need
it started with bottled water with
pictures of mountains on the face and
glorified tap water but quickly devolved
into something much dumber with
pseudoscience being used to get wealthy
people's money our founder quickly
realized there is money to be made in
monetizing the battles of these
behemoths and what can only be described
as the water wars for the dumbest
product on the market a coveted title
the winner usually stands to make
millions of dollars now today in the
left hand corner we have MOOC on day
seeing creator of live spring water the
first time I drank fresh living spring
water a surge of energy and peacefulness
entered my being
he's the Challenger of this event hoping
to upset in the right-hand corner mr.
Oshiro creator of kangen water first
let's take a gulp with onion water
let's go to the analyst desk to learn
more thanks Steven long time followers
of the water wars we'll know these two
pretty well but let's run down the stats
of these two real quick who are battling
for water supremacy our favorite of
course the window day is kangen water
they've been around for longer selling
alkaline water which you may have heard
of from your local Karen as an MLM and
definitely not a pyramid scheme
I repeat definitely not a pyramid scheme
you've heard of this on Facebook and
probably have been asked to buy it but
whether or not you are a believer kangen
water has an eye-popping $4,000 machine
which is definitely no laughing matter
and in this analysts opinion very very
dumb a tough contender to beat our
challenger today is of course the
creator of live spring water originally
named Christopher Sanborn it's unclear
why he chose to name himself makan day
Singh except to get all those sweet
Westerners dollars who want to believe
that something like mu Conde Singh means
there's something mystical about him he
doesn't sell a machine but he does
employ a subscription model of getting
water true to his California roots
pricing it at a respectable sixteen
dollars an orb with a minimum order of
four jugs which definitely may have been
the factor which got him past the semi
finals and of course this is pretty dumb
but is it dumb enough luckily for makan
day there's some questionable stories
about where he's getting his water so we
can only hope he has something more up
his sleeve because his viral marketing
campaign while it's undeniable isn't
going to be enough still though look at
that long haired hippy hike up the
mountains with tap water available in
everybody's faucet we've all got to
admit that is pretty dumb thanks for
that now let's get this thing started I
want to see a clean bpa-free fight here
today
Wow Ganga water started out with the
predictable water demonstration using
the old tea bag trick nothing ready
happen
let's try Kong in same teabag Kong in
that pure green color
I see supporter dollars flowing in
already not to be outdone though our
challenger fires back saying that his
live water has probiotics in it pristine
spring water that still has a lot of the
healthy probiotics in it now can we get
a fact check on that nope but it doesn't
seem to matter because it has done the
trick sales are through the roof he
follows it up with a predictable
rhetorical device I'm calling all his
competitors water dead water I could
never go back to drinking dead water
again Ganga water seems enraged by this
their alkaline water is losing sales
hippies are winning the hippies are
winning not only that they followed up
with a testimonial about the healing
powers of live water a woman compressed
meat again it's a miracle I had a
neighbor who wasn't able to breastfeed
her baby I shared some raw spring water
with her and she was able to breastfeed
her child again but what's this kangen
water fires back with a hot new video
about trying to light their water on
fire see he's gonna hear what exactly
are they trying to do here they say
they're testing it for active hydrogen
does that mean anything in terms of your
health nothing because the body
maintains a tightly controlled pH but
this is exactly the kind of dumb stuff
kangkang needs if they're gonna pull
ahead and man it's working at scoring
points with the crowd wait no hold on
I'm getting confirmation yes this is
impossible
yeah it's true makan day Singh may have
faked the idea that he's climbing up
mountains to get live water and it's
simply bottling at an organ water
facility instead of hiking down a
300-foot canyon to get to opal spring
the founder of live spring water is
actually getting his water from right
here opal Springs bottling company oh my
gosh this this match is over this match
is over I can't believe what I'm seeing
right now
Kangin water has
inde throw and I never thought I'd see
the day the reigning champ of the water
wars
but this California native was not to be
outdone he was not intimidated
he held tough and he ultimately came
away victorious we're gonna give him the
floor to give you final words here is
your water war 2020 Victor live water is
freshest within one lunar cycle because
it can turn green if the water gets too
hot it turns green because there's
healthy microbes in it
[Music]
never
[Music]
or the car
[Music]